là on va parler d'un drame terrible qui
a détruit toute une famille cet été un
jeune homme de 16 ans a été mortellement
fauché par un par un chauffard Noé aller
chercher des pizzas avec des amis un
homme de 43 ans alcoolisé et drogué
rentre dans sa voiture sans permis et le
tue après seulement 2 mois de prison cet
homme a été libéré entre une caution de
5000 €, une décision qui révolte
évidemment la famille alors qu'ils
viennent de déposer un texte de loi pour
faire bouger les choses la famille de
Noé nous dit sa colère sa volonté de
changer les choses et témoins de ce soir
dans TPMP regardez sur recap et c'est
vrai que c'est fou moi je savais même
pas que c'était possible mais voilà et
vous allez me dire ce que ce que vous en
pensez et si je sais que vous avez
manqué là-dessus c'est parti
l'été dernier la ville d'Antibes a été
touché par la mort tragique d'un
adolescent Noé en juin par un chauffard
ivre et sous l'emprise de stupéfiant
était à bord de sa voiture sans permis
lorsqu'il a été percuté par un homme
fortement alcoolisé drogué en excès de
vitesse un accident dramatique qui a
bouleversé de la Côte d'Azur on retrouve
des personnes complètement
irresponsables sur la route c'est pas
normal il faut que ça s'arrête mais
après seulement deux mois de détention
le chauffeur placé sous contrôle
du pur ressortir libre contre
une 5000 euros
une quiche aujourd'hui séparant qui le
vivent comme une véritable injustice on
trouve ça insupportable on comprend pas
cette décision
on donne 5000 € et on sort la colère de
la famille de Noé victime d'un chauffard
libéré sous caution ce soir dans TPMP
je remercie Christian le grand-père de
Noé et David l'oncle de Noé d'être avec
nous ce soir et c'est vrai que toute la
famille bien sûr et dévastée par cette
affaire et ce soir si vous voulez être
venu c'est aussi pour nous expliquer les
choses parce que vous savez pas du tout
que ça se passait comme ça moi j'ai j'ai
découvert ça en voyant votre affaire et
je pense qu'il y a énormément de de
Français qui ont découvert également ce
soir vous étiez donc l'oncle et le
grand-père de Noé qui avait 16 ans et
c'est dans la nuit du 24 au 25 juin
dernier que ce produit un drame
Noé 23 juin donc qu'est-ce qui s'est
passé c'est ce que je viens de dire il
était allez-y hein alors
mon neveu donc Noé
sors de son du domicile quoi avec ses
amis faire quelques courses
ils sont deux voies deux voitures qui se
suivent
à ce moment là
et pour pas faire de Malga gamme ou
baisser d'autres homonymes bon celui-là
il est la motoculture il a une
quarantaine d'années
il prend son véhicule un bolide
taux d'alcoolémie
plus qu'avancer
cocaïne est
donc tous ces faits que je lui dis bien
sûr il aurait été déjà
qu'une réalité malheureusement
vous avez été avéré tous ces films
donc il roule à tout à l'heure
les deux voiturettes se suivent
la première voiture est sur la droite
elle est
pour les percuter la voiture de mon
neveu
alors qu'il y avait c'était une route à
deux voies c'est à dire qu'il pouvait
être très bien rouler à gauche mais dans
un rivage tellement vite il est déporté
il a doublématique à la droite et pour
revenir et ben il a pris la voiture donc
il percute la voiture de mon neveu qui
va sur le la barrière de sécurité est
accompagné donc avec une amie on ne veut
17 ans
et là qu'est-ce qu'il fait
tu arrêtes
de quoi faire
pour aller voir la voiture pour aller
porter secours
pour voir ce drame qu'il a fait par son
comportement irresponsable non il
regarde d'abord l'état de sa voiture il
était moi
prends ton téléphone pas pour appeler
des secours non
quoi
c'est pas approcher de la voiture et il
va pour repartir bien sûr et les témoins
et les amis de Noé mais surtout une
personne un adulte qui est là qui a
porté bien sûr en plus des amis de Noël
et qui arracher les clés
à passer un jour de prison alors la loi
là maintenant elle est où
à la base
homicide involontaire avec circonstances
aggravantes c'est normalement 10 ans ça
va jusqu'à 10 ans et 150000 euros
d'amende
une caution de 5 c'est gros
il a présenté une représentativité c'est
à dire qu'il a un travail un toit il a
donné un domicile des enfants et voilà
des enfants et donc la justice a estimé
qu'il pouvait être remis en liberté et
ce qui a énormément surpris c'est
d'abord 5000 euros donc ça choque deux
mois seulement de détention et au moment
où il est libéré ce qu'on appelle la
commission rogatoire c'est à dire
l'intégralité de l'enquête n'est pas
encore revenue c'est à dire que c'est
comme si on le libère et Cyril avant de
savoir exactement ce qui s'est passé
c'est ça qui est doublement choquant et
libéré contre la vie du procureur parce
que ce récidiviste
déjà
c'est effectivement
la loi
était appliquée c'est ça je pense
qui vont prendre 5 ans de prison ou sept
ans de prison et ben ils vont réfléchir
allez dans les autres vont réfléchir
derrière ils vont réfléchir merci
Christian et David d'être venu nous voir
en tout cas il est important que